der chef der hells angels der nrw boss
des berüchtigten miri clans ein gangster
rapper mit millionen klicks und der
sicherheitschef des iranischen atom olaz
das alles klingt wie aus einem gangster
quartett ist in wahrheit aber ein
geheimnis verbrecher netzwerk im
mittelpunkt der mann hinter mir ramin
jagd apparat der in nrw ein mann
erschossen und zerstückelt haben soll
er ist der boss er marschiert vorweg
arme wie ein möbelpacker lederjacke
ramin nektar palast berüchtigte wurst
der mönchengladbacher hells angels mg
city gefürchtet gefeiert und gejagt die
polizei sucht den höllen engel mit
internationalem haftbefehl
der vorwurf rami nektar palast soll
einen angeblichen verräter ermordet und
zerstückelt haben jetzt ist er
abgetaucht er ist auf jeden fall ein
schwerstkrimineller die
staatsanwaltschaft sucht die nicht
umsonst mit internationalem haftbefehl
da gehört schon einiges zu so ein
haftbefehl dann auch beweiskräftigen
gericht vorzulegen zumindest den antrag
wir hatten eine kriminelle vereinigung
gefühlt zumindest aus kriminalistischer
sicht und deswegen ist es sicherlich im
umfeld der kriminalität eine exponierte
persönlichkeit bild recherchen zeigen
nun dem höllenengel ist es gelungen ein
geheimes netzwerk aus schergen und
helfern aufzubauen denn die bruderschaft
war für arminia passt schon immer heilig
und zusammenhalt kann sowas eigentlich
ganz und stande kommen club basiert auf
eine bruderschaft ja und das ist auch
gut so und sehr wichtig ganz einfach
der stückl mord im jahr 2014 ist eines
der spektakulärsten verbrechen im
rockermilieu bei m wird nach ansicht der
ermittler von seinen eigenen klub
brüdern eiskalt erschossen und dann mit
einer flex aus dem baumarkt zerteilt die
abgetrennten körperteile wurden
einbetoniert und versenkt im februar
2014 wurde hier am rheinufer das erste
leichenteile ist ermordet kkm gefunden
es war sein arm die polizei wusste
sofort auf grund der tätowierung es
handelt sich um einen hells angel eine
mordkommission wurde gebildet und die
ermittler gaben sieben jahre lang nicht
auf diesen fall endlich zu klären und
haben nun endlich das ergebnis und
wissen was damals hier passiert ist
ermittler sind sich sicher der stücke
rocker und seine schergen sind für die
bluttat verantwortlich
es kommt zum zugriff leonard geben und
alles ioc werden bei zwei spektakulären
razzien von spezialkräften überwältigt
der rechtsstaat kommt mit ramme
maschinenpistole und panzer die
spezialeinheit kam im morgengrauen durch
die tiefgarage dann haben sich
schwerbewaffnete elitepolizisten hier
hinter mir im treppenhaus stockwerk für
stockwerk lautlos vorgearbeitet im
dritten stock haben die männer dann die
ramme angesetzt und ein hells angels
rocker aus dem tiefschlaf gerissen mit
maschinenpistolen im anschlag haben sie
ihn überwältigt die bedrohung durch die
hells angels die abscheuliche tat die
spektakulären zugriffe das ruft sogar
den nordrhein westfälischen
innenminister auf den plan
gewitzt
zu lassen wir sagen die überschrift
heißt das heißt wieder verschlüsselt
gehandelt aber der mutmaßliche
haupttäter hatte sich vor den razzien in
seine heimat iran abgesetzt von einem
geheimen ort meldet sich rami nektar
palast nach festnahmen seiner brüder
selbst zu wort oder genauer er kämpft
mit den worten sie der polizei
beziehungsweise der ermittlungsbehörden
war es in den kommenden jahren bis heute
die zugriffe immer radikaler und
spektakulärer zu gestalten und damit zum
einen von
die von den einsatz einsetzen
betroffenen gefährlich gefährlich
gefährlich darzustellen und damit aber
eine durchsetzungsfähigkeit und stärke
zu demonstrieren die an der jeweiligen
stelle meist nicht erforderlich gewesen
ist bis heute ist unklar wann genau der
stücke rocker in den iran flow und so
den deutschen behörden durch die lappen
ging fakt ist kurz zuvor hatte er noch
die nerven in einem musikvideo zu
posieren an der seite von gangsta rapper
18 karat der musiker macht keinen hehl
daraus mit wem er sich da eingelassen
hat carmignac taba rast ist an diesem
tag nicht der einzige flüchtige
mafiabosse der im video posiert neben 18
karat und dem stücke rocker potts der
mini nrw boss des gefürchteten eric lanz
offenbar ebenfalls ein rahmen kumpel
dicke arme dickes konto und ebenfalls
von der polizei gesucht demiri soll nach
angaben der staatsanwaltschaft dortmund
mit rauschgift im großen stil gehandelt
haben an beweisen mangelt es nicht
allein 40.000 chat nachrichten wurden
entschlüsselt und dokumentieren die
kokain geschäfte mit einem
internationalen haftbefehl wird nach dem
clan chef gesucht der vorwurf
bandenmäßiger handel mit drogen
lange zeit ist unklar wo genau sich der
hells angels boss versteckt vor einigen
wochen veröffentlicht er dann ein
instagram video bild auswertungen
ergeben rami nektar parras kurs durch
den norden teherans in einer
wohlhabenden ausländern beliebten gegend
hier ist er offenbar eine neue
unheimliche allianz eingegangen bild
liegt dieses foto vor der stücke rocker
kuschelt mit dem atommüll a body guard
sein name hamed ascari ein held des
iranischen regimes verehrt auf den
titelseiten asghari war bodyguard des
außenministers zuletzt beschützte er den
kopf des iranischen atomprogramms mosen
fach sie hd mit mäßigem erfolg der
atommeiler wurde im dezember 2020 von
einem killerkommando erfolgreich
ausgeschaltet bodyguard hamad asghari
dabei schwer verletzt was bedeutet diese
neue unheilige allianz deutsche
ermittler sind alarmiert verbindung zur
organisierten kriminalität ist den
iranischen staat strukturen niemals
fremd gewesen die deutschen
sicherheitsbehörden müssen wachsam sein
auf jeden fall diese personen die hier
in rede steht verfügt über diese
kontakte und deswegen ist es wichtig für
sicherheitsbehörden seine mittäter und
seine kontaktperson hier bekannt in
deutschland weiter im rat zu haben
weiter zu beobachten damit wir hier
nicht ein einfallstor für starts
tourismus tatsächlich erleben solange
postet und polt der stücke rocker weiter
aus dem iran und droht den deutschen
behörden natürlich hat jedermann das
recht seine freiheit zu behalten oder um
diese zu kämpfen berlin gedroht wird
diese zu entziehen armin jäger passt
weiß im iran ist er sicher die mullahs
liefern landsleute nicht nach
deutschland aus und schon gar nicht wenn
es sich um einen freund des regimes
handelt mit einem netzwerk aus brutalen
helfern und stärken
[Musik]
ja und hier in deutschland ermittelt die
duisburger polizei weiter im fall des
ermordeten rocker die beamten fragen wer
hat damals am rheinpreußen hafen in
duisburg verdächtige beobachtungen
gemacht hinweise an die mordkommission
unter 0203